Rory Sutherland welcome to trigonometry
it's a joy to be here trigonometry I'm
Francis Prosser on constants and Kissin
and this is the show for you if you're
bored of people arguing on the internet
over subjects they know nothing about a
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts
we're here at the world-famous angel
comedy club and our amazing expert guest
this week is the columnist for The
Spectator vice chairman of the ovule v--
advertising group and one of the most
amazing creative counterintuitive
thinkers in the world today Rory
Sutherland welcome to trigonometry it's
a joy to be here
[Music]
so we always start with the with the
hoop with the question regardless of the
guess how did you come to be sitting at
this particular seat if I look for this
approximate reason I met Constantine at
kill Kannamma 'qs which I'm very very
happy to plug I have no financial
interest in it it's a festival in
Ireland every November and it's a
festival of economics and comedy and
it's an absolutely brilliant and
inspired idea not only is it in kilkenny
which is worth visiting at any time of
year but it's this idea of combining
kind of economic commentary with comedic
cynicism which creates actually a kind
of rare useful magic it's hugely useful
if you're interested in kind of
dissident economics or perverse
economics counterintuitive economics
it's inherently funny and rewarding in
its own right and we met there and
Constantine invited me on if you want to
go back to kind of deeper reasons oh we
did one of course I'm a huge fan of the
podcast there's a format please I'm very
fat and so the great phrase goes he's
got a great face for radio
I can put on makeup
appeals to be huge now I basically say
yes to any podcast invitation so tragedy
actually that everybody in radio
secretly wants to work in TV then I
think it's a terrible mistake
I think radio is a magical and audio in
general is a magical medium because with
a few hundred pounds worth of equipment
you can produce content that's
absolutely world-class Pramod television
the addition of pictures comes at a very
high price which is that the ratio of
[ __ ] around to radio producer he went
out with a set of recording equipment
and produced a documentary for Radio 4
on a Mongolian opera singers Wow that's
basically a return air tickets and you
know a large pocket to put your zoom
recording equipment in
that'll be the TV thing it would have
involved endless crap for actually not
very much added value so that's that's
another reason why I'm here running only
changed all those questions I ended up
in advertising I think advertising
appealed to me really as a greedy
comedian monkey which is I wanted to
work in a business which studied the
value of things that don't make
conventional sense and it strikes me
that if you look at humor in particular
the evolutionary origins of humor by the
way are really really interesting and
they're widely debated patently this
thing has some sort of value it allows
you or creates a context where you could
say things that are unsayable in another
context and if you look at the court
jester which is a role which is hundreds
of years old appears in Shakespeare goes
back to the early Middle Ages that's a
case where someone was allowed to speak
to power in a way that if anybody else
had said it would have resulted in
beheading or or social horror or
catastrophe so creating a space where
you can say unsayable things strikes me
is really important the reason there's a
connection between advertising in comedy
and it should be closer than it really
is when it one of the greatest ads that
Ogilvy ever produced which is the
diamond shreddies case where they
advertised new diamond shreddies by
simply presenting existing square
shreddies turned round through 45
degrees that was actually the work of a
comedian who was freelancing in Ogilvy
in Toronto oh wow now the real freedom
quite a lot of interesting creative
ideas are helped along if you have a
kind of Pythian a sense of humor that if
you have a kind of idea of a ridiculous
way to solve a problem nine times out of
ten maybe that solution remains
ridiculous
you know undoubtedly humors hugely
generative of creative possibilities
simply because it isn't constrained by
the usual rules of reason but on the
tenth occasion your ridiculous Python
asks
maybe contains a germ of truth that you
can orange maybe contains the germ of a
solution and so it strikes me as
fascinating as someone who just
generally loves comedy for the fact that
things that don't make sense can be so
brilliant I'm also fascinated by the
advertising world in that repeatedly for
all the efforts of kind of reductionist
economists to reduce human motivation to
something very very simple narrow and
self-interested there is patently a
whole load of stuff going on here which
we have yet to understand I think only
evolutionary psychology really will ever
uncover the true reasons I'll give you
just a perfect example of something that
happened the other day so we have a mail
pack that goes out to customers a very
large telecoms company and it's gone out
pretty much every year advertising what
they call a spring sale where you can
sign up to various products ala discount
and this year the response to this
mailing was about three times higher
that had been any previous yeah a people
would totally muffled by this and they
were basically scratching their heads
and they were obsessed with looking for
a rational explanation for the outcome
and they go around they don't they said
look you know the targeting was
basically the same it was the same group
of people it was essentially very
similar load of offers the pricing was
pretty much the same the creative you
know the content of the letter hadn't
really changed and yet it was three
times more successful I think around the
agency and they asked various people and
they come up with what you might call
post rationalized rational sounding
ideas finally they came to me I said
look and 53 years old I worked in
advertising for 30 years you're not
going to hear this explanation from
anybody else but I fundamentally believe
it's true
the reason it's three times more
successful is the envelope has lots of
pictures of fluffy rabbits on it the
theme they covered it with kind of
Illustrated cute rabbits one of very few
absolutely solid findings from the
advertising industry is that ads with a
nice animal in do better than
don't have a nice animal in it's
interesting ly the same with humor what
I find is a joke that illustrates the
point by using an animal tends to be
much funnier for the audience which I
think someone in Scotland did which is
jokes which involve a duck a somehow
slightly funnier than other jokes and
they had a debate about this whether
it's actually the word duck which has
comedic potential in the way that the
word goose doesn't okay or whether it's
just that the animal is inherently
slightly ridiculous but now I mean
undoubtedly anything anything animal
related just has and that's just a
evolved instinct that you don't that's
very interesting because when I was at
school monogamous geese are quite a few
ducks are yeah we had various warfare
when I was child who actually intensely
devoted to each other but the melons
were Boston's yeah absolutely yeah yeah
even I once had to explain to a special
needs child whilst trying to stop what
looked like a gang raped by a group of
mallards what was going on there's
essentially 25 Cromwell streets near
pond yeah because there's also there's
also infanticide and I think incest as
well about the whole the whole gamut I
have to be honest of all the subjects I
expected to come up with this was
certainly not one of them talk about the
value of comedy absolutely there is a
fundamental problem in politics and in
business which is you can only propose a
solution
if it makes sense hmm
now the problem with that is its context
independent that idea that you in other
words rationality is the only tool you
need to use to solve a problem the truth
the matter is is it looks like an
absolutely godlike economist John Kay I
think was a kill canonicus last year
he's made this point that the Faculty of
reasons dance bourbon sugar mercy a very
good book called the enigma of Reason
didn't evolve in humans to help us make
decisions if you think about it all
other animals mallards
dogs etc managed to survive and function
and reproduce perfectly well without
having to justify their actions
something about our nature as a social
species require us to have a Faculty of
reason either to stress test collective
decision-making or to justify our
behavior
to others but it didn't evolve to
actually help us decide and so nearly
everything this is where advertising and
comedy I think have an overlap and where
behavioral science naturally lends
itself to comedic value which is all of
us essentially have a view of ourselves
which we project hmm as to why we do
things and what we do and we have a real
deep down reason which is buried and
hidden not only from everybody else but
also from ourselves it's one of the most
important I think theories in psychology
Robert rivers idea that we actually
deceive ourselves in order the better to
deceive others that if we actually had
essentially full introspective access to
our motivation then essentially we blow
it by giving a game away and so we need
to practice self-deception in order to
actually maintain a an acceptable facade
for everybody else now once you realize
that of course what you realize is that
one of the things comedy does is it
points out the very obvious discord
between the reasons we we give and the
real reasons for various actions and I
always find it really really interesting
but the idea that things have to make
sense is a very dangerous one so it
interesting things about capitalism is
for all its faults it can stumble on
things and fund them even when they make
no sense so when I give a talk I usually
give this great example of a fantastic
product which is ostensibly a complete
nonsense now if you've been asked let's
say 30 years ago to compete with Coca
Cola you were sat down and you were sat
around a table and said we need a drink
that tastes nicer than coke cost less
than Coke and comes in a really big can
see we all get great value for money and
everybody would have known it and you
would have gone off you would have done
it and you probably would have failed
hmm
meanwhile the most successful attempt to
compete with coke in 150 years red Bull
okay comes in a tiny can cost a fortune
tastes disgusting there's a second order
logic to that I think which is the
disgusting taste is actually essential
to the overall experience
we deeply weird you if you were given
really nice tasting medicine wouldn't it
yes know something about the placebo
effect even if you want us to believe
instinctively that something has
psychoactive or medicinal powers it has
to taste weird
so our health food has to taste [ __ ]
yeah basically I mean it's very you know
I mean otherwise it's not healthy
otherwise wheatgrass I mean I think the
other side of your Flymo you can say but
because it tastes kind of weird we
automatically infer from that that it's
probably doing us some good oh you're
having some interesting effects
high-price also adds to that effect the
small can makes it look as if this drink
is so damn potent if I had a full 375
milliliters I can't go postal okay and
so what's interesting about this is that
it is impossible to get any idea through
what you might call the reason police
unless it first meets the criterion of
being expected now this is wrong in a
search for problem solving you should
ask the self question even if it doesn't
make sense
empirically does it work that's about
what I was about to say because isn't a
big part of what you might expect a
reason to be as empiricism
other words using data from testing to
see whether something works on a rather
than just going oh in my head logically
this doesn't make sense I'm an empirical
monarchist okay in that no one would
create a hereditary monarchy in a
constitutional democracy from scratch
you wouldn't just go here's Barry we'll
take his family and Wilson choosing
people by lot actually isn't it is
another interesting area which we need
to explore and that's how Greek
democracy worked but the other thing is
if you're looking empirically the
connections of countries in the world
which are basically constitutional
monarchies okay so you've got Canada
Australia New Zealand the UK you've got
Holland Belgium Spain
thus candies you've got so you've got
other than Finland you Sweden Norway
Denmark okay you've got Japan and pretty
much about 90% of the countries in which
you'd actually want to live have that
system of government now what I'm saying
is just because it doesn't make sense
doesn't mean it may not have some virtue
that's simply difficult to explain or
difficult to quantify absolutely one of
the things I'd see with creativity is
it's a way of actually breaking out of a
very very narrow straitjacket of
decision finding I mean the thing that
started as a joke with me if you ask the
question already any why am I here and I
suppose one of the reasons I'm here is I
gave a TED talk back in about 2009 I
think it was yeah yeah so that's nine
years ago now and I simply made the
Eurostar gang oh it's fantastic
fantastic little story okay I know you
thought about it a couple of days
beforehand the point was that they were
spending six billion pounds building
high-speed rail tracks between some
Pancras and chem coast to reduce the
overall journey time between London and
Paris London and Brussels as well by
about 25 minutes okay now my snarky
little suggestion was look
what is a bit weird is we're spending
six billion on these rail tracks and the
trains this was true until two years ago
okay
so the trains don't have Wi-Fi now I
don't know our southeastern trains which
you share with me from Tunbridge Wells
they're now installing Wi-Fi they are I
actually get half the time I'm actually
annoyed my train arrives Severn Bridge
to get here today I stayed on until
Charing Cross because I was in the
middle of something if you put Wi-Fi on
something essentially time loses its
meaning okay but also you're perfectly
productive or entertained so actually
you know the time doesn't matter nearly
as much so you can reduce what you might
call perceptual journey time not at the
cost of six billion which is what it
costs to reduce actual journey time you
can reduce it at a cost of what's
prominently five million six million
which is literally naught point one
percent of the cost I said look if you
want to be more perverse and I just got
silly that I said you know if you really
want to improve the Eurostar you had a
budget of six billion you'd hire all of
the world's top male and female
supermodels get them to walk up and down
the train handing out free shut it /
truce to all the passengers you saved 5
billion pounds it would cost you about a
billion pounds to do that and people
would ask for the trains to be slowed
down totally that is what you might call
the advertising cousin to a comedic
technique which is the reframing joke
yes which is you tell something you know
they're you know the most boring thing
is you know you know that joke which
seems completely innocent until you flip
the context by saying that you know I
you know I was masturbating the other
day bla bla bla bla and then something
introduced about that it was in
Sainsbury's yeah the same thing takes on
basically what is goes for a selfie what
you might call a little bit reveal it
early say
but you would never but the the obscene
thing there is that it's exactly the
same thing which is that human
decision-making is quite often and human
perception is badly constrained by
conceptual frame or what you might call
a mind trap and comedy is one of the
ways in which you can liberate yourself
from this so I'll give you a little
real-world story which is you may
remember it's one of my favorite
sketches even though as I said it makes
no sense it's a Rowan Atkinson sketch
from not one o'clock news where he goes
into a bathroom showroom and they have
very cast no bottle showers bars etc in
which he can actually design his own
bathroom and he just decides he's gonna
have a bathroom with seven timer okay
totally bonkers gorgeous right anybody
who's seen it will still remember it 35
years later someone comes to me with a
problem which is the fireman in certain
American cities when they're not
fighting fires which actually is most of
the time because smoke detection
equipment and so on and vastly less
flammable fabrics have reduced the
incidence of of domestic fires Christ's
super significantly so they go around
typically to poorer areas in the u.s. to
housing projects and they try and
install smoke detectors for free
perfectly Noble and worthwhile things
too now one of the things they can never
get their head around I can't understand
it either entirely is that they can get
nearly everybody and they ring on the
door and say fine I'm here we're just
here to install a smoke detector you
basically you get them to install one
but they really balk at two or three and
the typical apartment really needs three
was frenzy is that's like saying no I
don't want one in my child's bedroom
it's a really weird thing say but for
some reason people just draw the line at
one maybe two when three is necessary
okay now I used that same Caterpie flask
you know bizarre approach
to suggest a solution which is very
simple thing in behavioral science is
just reacting I said it partly was okay
i partly suggested absolutely outrageous
things which which would never be legal
or acceptable which is to actually
outrage people by saying you know well
actually if you're korean you'd be
entitled to three but since you're
african-american you ain't again - so
you you absolutely cause some sort of
outrage now and Competitiveness in
comparison but that tape for a friend of
mine whose wife was Chinese he was
invited to visit South Africa and she
didn't go in the end but she wasn't
allowed to share the same hotel with him
and they rang up and said his young wife
Chinese or Japanese he said she's
Singaporean Chinese are unfortunately or
Gillian said in a different hotel she
wasn't asleep all about setting the
different hotel for hours but the idea
that had she been Japanese it would have
been okay drove her practically yes yes
we forget this fact actually it's one of
the problems of the British left they
assumed complete harmony among all
external ethnic groups well the Chinese
Japanese rivalries and with some reason
in some cases yes still pretty intense
but okay so one of the things I one of
the reasons and this is why free speech
and advertising by the way and free
speech in comedy
are both really really important things
to fight for now no one is suggesting
for a second I'm never gonna do that
okay but it just struck me as a really
interesting idea or how to get people to
accept free is to suggest that they
weren't actually but one of the ideas
about how you get younger children to
eat insects is to have a part of notice
you say well unfortunately because
you're under 16 you won't be allowed to
eat you know basically you know the
magazine thing there's a get in just 17
had an average readership age of about
13 you know you know so actually telling
people that you're not eligible for
something drives them practically insane
that's interesting but but then the
reason the free speech thing is
important is because
there is a whole area of ideas which
belong in an ad agency which I would
describe as you'd get promoted for
making the suggestion and fired for
enacting it and that one that I suggest
is an example of that okay if you
actually have the idea I'd be impressed
by your ingenuity if you actually
executed it I'd be horrified by your
lack of judgement say that this is
really really important because one
speech is experimental action so
applying the same criteria to speech as
you do to physical actions is ridiculous
because one of the reasons we've evolved
humour and speech is it's nature's
flight simulator it's where we try
things out without actually doing them
and probably the road of stories or
whole bunch of things exists as a kind
of simulation but the second thing is
sometimes in advertising in in problem
solving of any kind you kind of have to
climb Mount silly to get to the bright
sunlit uplands below but look beyond
what I eventually suggested borrowing
for that Rowan Atkinson sketch for the
smoke to take thing as I said chair
number six that six is ridiculous number
and if you say to the people well you
know we normally bring six smoke
detectors to our home but I think here
you can make do with three or four
you'll probably get them to install for
three or four and three in fact because
one now seems weirdly on the low side
once you've acted them at six one the
seems like well then we'll have one
that's insanity right and so having the
ability to say and think and I would
argue the principle value of an ad
agency isn't actually the production of
advertising or communication it's the
existence of a culture with a client
company's interests at heart but with a
culture in which it is possible to say
ridiculous things and still get promoted
there that's one of most important
things than that agency can have is the
ability to say something totally
ridiculous which in say the civil
service would be career suicide or in
politics
would probably be career suicide unless
you you know unless you're a Boris
Johnson you managed to kind of there's a
bit of me which goes Jesus you know I
mean I don't like what he says but at
least at least I believe him when he
says it yeah I think a lot of people
feel that way that's one of the reasons
he probably thought alike that you know
where you are with a good playing crop
which is that the elite priestly caste
has become basically weird it's become
fixated with a very very narrow world
view which is instilled in all those
kind of religious ceremonies that take
place in divorce or business schools or
whatever which are all inculcating
exactly the same creed okay now I'm
conservative I'm not making this as a
kind of weird left-wing point but I
don't I don't think anybody can
reasonably say that there's a complete
lack of imagination and weirdness in
politics and business which is that it's
become obsessed with an incredibly
narrow way of defining worldly progress
and success mostly around efficiency and
cost reduction which is not really very
well aligned with what people really
care about absolutely well that's one of
the reasons we want to chat in by the
way I love speaking with you and one of
the reasons is we've asked you how you
got here and that was you win the award
for the most articulate and elaborate
answer to that question probably the
history which I was born in and badeck
which he just answered ask and the the
the most famous son by a factor of two
hundred and Bannock was Alfred Russel
Wallace and say my little ambition is to
be the second best evolutionary thinker
born in that paddock and one of the well
she wouldn't compete is it that they
built daily is it keyboard yes he's I
think the president of the Wallace
Society there is I think this is also
true of our certainly speaking to Jimmy
Carr there is a very very close tie
between comedians and an interest in
evolutionary psychology absolutely I
mean if you wanted to know what comedies
pet academic discipline is I think
evolutionary psychology wins every time
I think psychology by the way gets into
trouble for similar reasons to comedy so
in academia one of the reasons why
behavioral economists are very reluctant
to investigate any history psychology as
an explanation for human behavior is
that if you are in that kind of
Darwinist camp it's incredibly easy to
get you know no platformed and generally
abused and of course I suppose that's
the other reason why evolutionary
psychologists too close to comedians
which is they both have that slight urge
to go slightly closer to the edge
there's politic and yes
[Music]
one of the things that I know that you
well actually we'll talk about that
stuff later because you keep bringing up
the issue of free speech and I think
that's something that we've been talking
about recently we we had today as we're
recording this we're releasing an
episode with a guy who Co writes for
Jonathan PI I don't know if you've seen
this but he's a guy who he was a
reporter who keeps getting caught after
he's delivered his professional report
ranting about whatever subject he's just
reported on I don't know if you've seen
that but anyway we were talking to him
about free speech and it seems to me
like you keep bringing that up because
do you feel that it's under threat in
this country do you feel that the way we
are conducting our conversations isn't
the way that we should well first first
of all there's something slightly weird
about it okay which is no one one of the
things about the social justice movement
is no one asks John generally it's quite
benign I mean they think they're clever
if you look at most social justice
campaigns what you find is they're
basically Quakers who are late to the
party kuben I mean cool Ben 5500 years
ago would have been a Quaker he's just a
Quaker monkey and it's actually
hostility I've got no hostility to the
diagnosis you know I would generally
argue that the direction of travel is
right but by obsessing over little
shibboleths
like whether what a comedian said might
be offensive to some imaginary listener
who frankly shouldn't be in a bloody
comedy club in the first place if
they're that sensitive okay when you
enter a comedy club you are at some
level deciding to be shocked okay
I would argue there is huge progress to
be made in quite a few areas of justice
where the focus on those tiny little
what you might call those tight you know
relatively trivial little it's about the
vegan debate about whether or not you
eat honey you know the focus on those
tiny little things that set people apart
is ultimately a distraction
from what could be far greater games so
you know I mean one problem would be
that the weirdness of the most
vociferous members of the social justice
movement actually set back its causes
okay now you know I've got a daughter
who's vegetarian I occasionally argued
look if you get really really purist
about this
so one vegetarian a friend of mine
basically after about 20 years of pure
vegetarianism started eating prawns
because his argument was they didn't
have a central nervous system and the
inconvenience you suffer going to
restaurants if you're simply prepared to
eat prawns basically vanishes okay and I
suggested actually that you should make
insects acceptable for vegetarians to
eat because actually it's a it's a very
environmentally friendly way of
producing high protein foods now there
is huge progress to be made in I think
animal welfare okay which I would really
raise support and yet if you make the
whole thing about some completely
bizarre tiny tiny trivial point about
the fact that and I personally got
grumpy I understand their reasons for it
which is all about disgust okay which is
vegetarians you get very upset if the
pizza bread that they're vegetarian
kebab was being made in happen to touch
a bit of the donor okay because I
supposing that's not about any kind of
rational reason for vegetarian that
that's basically religious purity okay
that's the religious purity instinct
that isn't the utilitarian instinct at
play okay it patently you know resting
against the Donna is not irrelevant in
terms of animal welfare okay and what
you're doing there is you're making
people like me who would actually become
very largely vegetarian less likely to
become vegetarian because I don't want
to become that kind of weird crank okay
so it is just as there's a phrase that
you know the great is the enemy of the
good in some cases the perfect is the
enemy of the better
in in in wild today about driverless
cars saying the whole things being
screwed up because they're aiming too
high okay they're aiming for a perfectly
driverless car which can whiz around and
do everything that a human driver can do
well ultimately we'll get there but the
way to actually succeed is to aim first
for the middle and they said look if you
had for example a network of roads to
take teenagers home where the cars could
just drive along a painted line on the
road between 10 and 10 p.m. or 10 p.m.
and 2 a.m. and they could only drive at
20 miles an hour and they drove
themselves or you had pods
transportation which was just a network
of little cars or pods that just
circulated around London on totally
preordained routes I make it cycle lanes
personally they're cycling cycling is
you know the cycling is basically races
do you know that engine I'm not white
enough to cycle designated lanes around
London or very simple networks have
little pods going around driving
themselves not hitting people you would
demonstrate a huge proportion of the
benefits of something without
necessarily trying to reach perfection
when you try and reach perfection you
end up people getting killed people
getting frightened etc a cyclist for
example justice bhuvan's this [ __ ] about
cultural appropriation oh yes this is
patently okay intellectually okay what
the hell happens to katsu curry right
catsuit curry is a Japanese dish
introduced from India by the British
okay I mean who's the Japanese basically
appropriate here for the Indians of the
British can I eat it well I mean you
know attaching that to kind of dress for
example is patently insanity because the
asymmetry of the whole thing becomes
actually obvious you know I mean I mean
no one would dream for a second of
suggesting that you know Indian was
playing cricket was cultural preparation
and yet you do the same thing the other
way
and if I were to turn up here in one of
those narrow jackets
you know I get a lot of [ __ ] there's
something so bonkers about it it doesn't
matter that much right I mean you know
there's a huge instance of modern
slavery there's enormous animal
suffering there are also campaigns we
can engage in collectively if we could
only get them started which wouldn't
benefit one tightly defined ethnic or
gender group but they could benefit
everybody so let's take this example of
it is I think whatever the arguments for
why women end up earning less than men
which bear in mind of course higher
earners reflect the gender balance of a
business thirty years ago yes okay so if
you look at Ogilvy my graduate
recruitment group in Ogilvy was three
males to one female which was probably
pretty normal at the time whatever
reason okay if places that recruited
from Oxbridge it's worth remembering
that four years before me at Oxbridge
though most of the colleges were all
male so you know what you see now is
actually a reflection of what happened
40 years ago you know the question is
you just have to accept a drift path
dependency and this stuff but if you
look at that okay there's a campaign
which you could make for women to be
given greater maternity rights but also
greater freedom for flexible working now
why make that agenda based campaign if
you look at the United States okay
something like 68 percent of Americans
if you ask them would rather have four
four percent less money than two weeks
more vacation I don't know if you know
this in the u.s. interesting thought
experiment here about how this is what I
call mine trap in other words if you
think something's normal it's very
difficult to be the first person to make
a change okay so a lot of change happens
you know it was very very and I'm not
suggesting it's easy now okay but the
difference between coming out in you
know in 2018 and coming out in 1968 okay
you know an order of magnitude or
something no one's suggesting it's easy
at any time but nonetheless you know the
first person to do something pays a
disproportionately high price yeah but
then as more and more people stop and
the social norm becomes established okay
the price becomes lower and then notice
things bowing their loads of things
which follow this very unequal path if
you look at bebo change so I'll give you
two great examples of this if you look
at how social change happens but the
standard kind of economic idea is we're
all individual actors it's called
methodological individualism and we just
go actually I think that's wrong but
Quakers we're way in advance on that one
as well or is it just practice Quakers
on things like slavery there people
extraordin my wife's an Anglican vicar
but they're really religious to people
like John Woolman in the United States
who you know if you stayed in a
household where there were slaves you
left the money that the slave would be
paid as a servant behind because that
was the only acceptable way he could
resolve it and this was by way I mean
this was you know 18th century stuff
this was really really quite early a
better man if it's slavery was a mind
trap I mean everybody thought for a long
long time everybody thought it was
perfectly normal it was in the Bible it
happened for thousands of years remember
this that you know they're you know
having a go at people in the in the in
the 18th century for not being
abolitionists ok he's you know he's a
little like having a go you know people
for not being gay rights campaigners in
1926 or something okay
it's a different order of difficulty
yeah so a lot of things happen either so
an interesting example of this where
everybody gets the costs first of the
benefits only come when something
becomes more widely adopted that applies
to London taxis accepting credit cards
okay now I've spoken loads of London
taxi cab drivers and it was the threat
from uber that made them do it to great
extent but they do grudgingly admit that
since they accepted credit cards and
particularly content as credit cards
usage of black
has gone up dramatically because it was
a complete anomaly that London had this
cab system where you couldn't
confidently get in a cab knowing that
you know if the journey over ran a bit
and you ran out of cash you could just
use a credit card to pay they created a
whole lot of uncertainty and anxiety and
reluctance to use cabs partly because if
you think about it
contactless payment has meant that we
carry less and less cash and using a cab
became the single biggest drain on your
cash reserves you know was okay so it
pays them all to accept credit cards
they're all better off okay but in the
end they made it compulsory because they
just decided until you hit about
nineteen ninety ninety five percent it
doesn't benefit anybody the person who
is an early adopter of credit cards
stuff as all of the costs transaction
costs general hassle but you know
people's cards not working waiting for a
receipt therefore have disproportionate
cost no benefit it's only when it's 95
cent where the punter can confidently
have a cap now you could have had an
intermediate solution of the problem
which is cabs that accepted credit cards
could have displayed a different color
light say so consumer choice could have
driven the adoption of the credit card
but because of the problem where by the
time you'd hail the cab it was too late
to go you could really say you don't
take credit cards piss off okay
because of that social awkwardness that
the order effect essentially what you
had was no incentive to accept something
because the early adopters paint the
highest price and there are loads and
loads of things which I think follow
that curve now if you think about it 68%
of people in America would rather have
more vacation a bit less money I'm not
sure by the way the economy wouldn't be
better off of that more holiday cuz
leisure expenditure is much more labour
generative than just buying [ __ ] from
Walmart which is what they tend to do
Americans also tend to a [ __ ] thing
really which is they have loads and
loads of conferences in sort of sunny or
exotic places which is that's a vacation
for you talking about marketing and you
kind of treat that as if it's a holiday
total crap okay now that's interesting
case way to think about it all 68
percent of people in every firm would
rather make that trade-off between
leisure and money but the first person
to try and make that call he's gonna pay
a disproportionate price because they
become known as the lazy guy yeah yeah
yeah this happened in Sweden actually
getting them to take paternity leave Ben
and various you know muscies know things
about wishing to signal commitment to
their employer would kind of take two
days early
when they're entitled more in the end
they made it compulsory to create a
social norm so it was just accepted that
the guy is gonna be off work yeah that's
the end of it and so there's certain
things where you need to reach a
critical mass before you can get
anywhere where I think social justice
stuff goes a bit weird is that it's
often focusing on stuff that's already
tipped
trying to reach a kind of level of
perfection you know I mean generally
really nasty racist people they're still
around but they're gonna kind of die
don't spend your whole time going insane
because some guy said something nasty
you know or whatever why don't you focus
on those things you know instead as I
said don't make bloody greater leisure
time a feminist campaign make it a
universal one there are loads and loads
of guys and people out there who would
want to make the trade-off between
slightly less money slightly more spare
time and actually the arguments they can
find it to some blasted identity group
what's certain or actually then the
argument is as well as if men can take
more paternity time that will allow
women to get back to work quicker
potentially
I think that paying opposed there are
some kind of analyses which suggest that
the disparity of earnings it can be
entirely attributable to time spent in
maternity and that if you look at the
career progression of people who haven't
had children of any reason it doesn't
show the same dead I don't think it's
just that I don't think it's just
prejudiced by the way yeah no no I think
that that I slight thing that annoys
with the social justice movement is they
can only see the world in terms of
prejudice discrimination race gender and
oppressor and oppressed group etc and I
mean one interesting thing which always
interest me is you know it's perfectly
possible of course that women oppress
other women it doesn't have to be so
this question all right I can't let you
leave it there because if it stays there
it's gonna be very unexplained the
trigger of looking what do you mean by
women as well which undoubtedly imposes
a burden on my daughters that's that's
great because at least you'll be quickly
[Laughter]
these new feminists who worries about
foundation cream and the high lashes in
the [ __ ] okay which strikes me as a bit
weird but that's not no I don't know
where that comes from me you have some
Darwinist from sense inmate other people
would say it's peer pressure it's not
guys right if you look at the women's
fashion industry it is not driven by
male desire I've never looked at him for
fashion magazine in my life and
generally guys don't read them equally
you can say that I don't think anybody's
ever been apparently okay has been
watching porn haven't they oh my god
that's last year's journey visage
actually for women to dress in a way
that's attractive to men is quite easy
though winter to tell you how to do that
right okay you know you know and so so
there's something going on there now you
know I asked you about this now ask the
question are there cases where we're
trapped social norms essentially imposed
collective costs which all of us would
rather not bear individually okay but
which are inescapable simply because of
this sigmoid curve that anybody who
deviates pays disproportionately high
costs so like in this case of woman that
doesn't wear makeup for example we just
wear red boiler suits
it makes the office look like the
headquarters of a James Bond okay we get
a monorail but also it may be Friday
maybe Friday people enjoy this [ __ ] but
I'm the only person in the world who
also wants these bloody cookery shows
banned and it's okay because they set
the bar too high all right so it used to
be that basically if you invited some
people around your house you provided a
tolerable bounds of free booze and
something to eat which couldn't be at
peace all right you are a host that was
doing your job and you had a fantastic
time but it's 90 percent of the pleasure
and such evenings isn't rated by the
food
it's grated by the company combined by
the drunkenness okay yeah right it's not
really about you know I mean I can't
remember what I ate at my wedding I
can't remember what I ate at loads and
loads of things it's not about that
but these cookery shows essentially set
the bar so ridiculously high for what
cancers baking what cancers cooking that
will end up having far fewer sociable
evenings because people simply can't
face it
hmm I think that loads of thing is there
there's a great book which I advise
everybody read called the Darwin economy
by my friend Robert H Frank and he talks
about what you might call peak I was
Tale effects in human behavior where the
competitive
and Phatak me if you think about it it's
all very well for economists to say that
never all that matters is individual
utility relative wealth doesn't matter
lately we didn't evolve that way
there are lots and lots of things in
life which depend actually access to
high-quality partners to an extent okay
that's a relative question it's not an
absolute one and I think yes you live in
Denmark where you automatically get a
Danish wife which is probably gonna be
okay
I'd say that reminds me of a story I
remember once when I was in my early
twenties and he said he went he asked me
he went to me Francis are you single I
went yes and this was about 11 o'clock
and he went but I've got one piece of
advice for you oh god I've got what is
it daddy went go to Copenhagen in the
summer and he walked out the room I'm
going to Copenhagen with my girlfriend
in summer
I think the urge to we have an in nature
to outdo other people okay and I mean
that's what drives comedy that's what
makes London comedy amazing is precisely
that the bar set very high no one wants
to completely dismiss competitive urge
because it leads to the most spectacular
things but also leads to a kind of
collective stupidity and misery for
something and misery and also also we
tend possibly to if you look at
universities for example we look at the
we do a a benefit analysis if you didn't
really do a cost analysis all the over
30 are the worst 30% or 40% of people
coming out of universities actually
worse off because of the existence and
proponents of higher education we never
measured this we just go gosh look at
these very successful people and they
all went to university so universities
brilliant it's basically a factory for
producing really successful people and
we failed who asked the question well
actually what about the people who did
quite Hackett are they actually screwed
you have this bonkers system now where
companies weren't interview people who
haven't got a 2-1 so I meant someone who
had a 2-2 in maths from Cambridge and
they couldn't get a job interview I said
trust me okay I've never met any
mathematical problem that couldn't be
solved in business by someone with a
tutu in maths from Cambridge I said if
we do meet one you'll know loads of
people to go to first you can ring them
up an ass okay it's not a big deal right
so you know you gotta you gotta do
Cambridge to do maths I think it's fair
saying you're not kind of enumerated
right you come across my bar there you
know and so so there is this thing which
is that you've got you know you've got
to ask the question about that first of
all the the obsession with and I think
the obsession with tiny my new T is the
social justice movement is actually a
product in this competitive urge that in
order to show affiliation to a group the
way you've proved it's exactly like
football I don't I don't like football I
think it's irrational there's reason
that which is not that I don't like
football is that I grew up or in the
Seven Valley region in the 1960s or 70s
where essentially we were in the HTV
West TV area okay now the local football
teams the nearest Premiership team then
was probably Aston Villa in fact which
was about 80 or 90 miles away or more
okay the typical local news thing would
say and another bad night for west
country football fans City and Rovers
both lost and Swindon could only manage
a draw that it didn't really incentivize
you to turn up on the terraces and get
involved but I've never understood it
but just as people prove their loyalty
to a football team by engaging in ever
more bizarre and ridiculous antics
people will you know essentially signal
their adherence to a cause by doing the
same thing and I think I think it's a
dangerous thing because actually it's
self-defeating
essentially the first people to adopt a
technology can be a disaster for the
technology you know soon I mean if the
people who adopt something are generally
weird
yeah but obsessive and keep ranting on
about it it's not actually encouraging
to other people they just go clearly at
something for weirdos I'm gonna leave it
leave it alone hmm perfectly good
intentions can get distorted into
something that's actually about
self-defeating in that way but it's very
interesting it's when you say that
because you have two people who had to
take free speech and then then they get
retweeted by Katie Hopkins yeah Oh Tommy
Robinson and then people go see I told
you this was nonsense
look who's supporting you this is a
bizarre one because it should be
perfectly possible for people across the
spectrum and I think it's been all good
for comedy I gotta be honest about it
just comedy actually pretends to be left
way okay some level there is always a
degree of mild nastiness okay
of course it always has to be it has to
be victim is extreme but I mean it's
like tickling according to the
evolutionary psychologist which is a
form of physical contact where it's very
clear for the contact it could go the
context that no harm is intended okay so
this theory by the I think it's a
Colorado academic that actually humors
essentially verbal tickling yep
so there's always something of you know
if you think about it very few comedians
will stand up and go you know I voted
Tory my taxes outrageous who would be
the but equally they very frequently
adopt personas which you know slightly
you know patently you have to adopt a
persona the pub landlord or bridge of a
sexually as bread you know which are
kind of everyman personas which are a
bit right-wing and it's complicated but
the free speech thing is caught people
slightly
an open position because I think comedy
patently it's an existential threat to
comedy if you if you have this problem
where Chris Rock refuses to play the
American College circuit because it's
just not worth the [ __ ] you lucky
bastard University no once you get to
that point it's basically impossible
okay because it can't it can't because
it's there to point out to some extent
okay sit comedy is essentially hostile
to what you might call the New Jerusalem
project of the left which is the idea
that it's much much easier to live in an
imaginary future than it is to live in a
messy present and comedy points out the
fact that this life is messy okay there
is a conflict between what we would like
to think of ourselves and how we really
are okay there are widespread
absurdities in kind of human behavior
and human emotion and so on and comedy
is there to actually point out the
imperfect ability of things whereas
somebody said the worst of the left are
actually essentially you know start with
you know start with weird New Jerusalem
dream world basically go bonkers
wherever world current worlds differs
from that world have no discussion about
the paths necessary to get from A to B
but simply get very very angry and upset
now that's kind of problematic because
it's it's also hugely problematic
because context is really really
important so I would imagine okay within
a military platoon there is unbelievable
abuse of every kind but keep taun each
other okay you know now would you want
to police within you know a group of
twenty or thirty crack soldiers would
you actually want to police their
language in that way
well the truth of the matter is what you
say to the other person is a it's
actually weirdly a perverse sign of
affection because it's it's it's exactly
like a person
signaling in animals you know this thing
where poisonous animals tend to be
brightly colored right so lady birds
they spend all my life on a [ __ ] leaf
right so you think that green might be a
good kind of fashion choice right no red
black why mimicry it's actually the
opposite of it's actually essentially
saying I must be inedible because if I
weren't inedible for some reason there's
no way I could get away with this bad
ass coloration yeah it's probably why
you wear jewelry in South Central Los
Angeles okay now it's not just to prove
what you can afford is to prove what you
can get away with okay now as you know
vice chair advertising agency could
probably afford quite a large gold
necklace I don't think I'm safely
wearing that stuff in public basically
proves that you're a badass they secrete
a disgusting chemical from their knees
now appluse Matic signaling is basically
I show that I'm something because if I
weren't that thing I couldn't get away
with this but actually we prove we're
friends particularly Brits Americans
sometimes get this wrong by being rude
to our friends oh yes absent the person
you abused is paint with your mate
because if you weren't my mate we
couldn't get away with this level of
banter and bad in Osh okay
so there's an app for somatic quality to
ruins down a military group all they
really care about whether you're rude
about my face my origins whatever would
you die for me okay that's that's the
central question okay
and if you want to foster that kind of I
mean it will probably be progress okay
if in 20 or 30 years mild homophobic
bang banter takes place between you and
game ends okay in Britain they'll
actually probably be a mark of progress
I'm not sure that's going to happen I'm
not sure it's desirable because you can
make all sorts of arguments about it but
nonetheless the fact that you can do
that it's much much more complicated
than taking everything that people say
completely literally because the whole
point of speech is completely weird in
this respect anyway
the way we interpret words entirely
depends on the words either side of them
no word has a set meaning depends on
tone of voice in many cases which is why
and I'm always very worried when I see a
case in the paper where someone's words
are written down okay something someone
is aggrieved because they claim their
boss was okay
now I'll give you a classic case of this
which is that I think there's a case
where someone at a bank they were
traveling on a private plane and the
male's suggested that she served them
drinks on the thing okay
this was like 1992 okay it's pretty iffy
when you read it on paper it was
probably pretty iffy in reality but
there's a 10% chance if well-intentioned
and the two people were actually friends
that's exactly what would happen amongst
a bunch of mixed gender friends okay you
know so it's very very difficult to
judge speech in print because the
twinkle in the eye it can completely
change the meaning of what said well
interestingly enough nowadays quite
often when you see a story like that
where somebody said something offensive
even the content of what they said is
not reported so you will often see an
article where you are told that somebody
made an offensive comment and you're not
even given the opportunity to to see the
comment even though this really bothers
me the hell out of me because what the
hell the real word there which you gotta
watch out for is inappropriate okay
I mean that's objective in appropriate
is the subjective comment and it's also
a contextual comment okay and so you're
absolutely right about that or also I've
noticed increasing things saying you
know performed a sexual act okay
puritanical I run into Stephen Fry who's
basically a bit of a lefty lovey
he's saying he's he's bad what are you
spotting about this which i think is
fair is that there's a degree of this
which is Puritanism in disguise it's a
kind of it's a really unpleasant weird
Puritanism that's actually taken on a
political rather than the religious
mantle but the you know I think that the
what you might call the general fund
brigade the bomb fever brigade
I've got to fight this cause because at
some level it's going to lead human
relations to become deeply miserable and
constrained and and nervous I mean to
that extent it's worrying but I know the
other point is that you know I mean what
you say jokes the context-dependent
I don't think free speech is
context-dependent I think you just got
to accept the whole lot I mean not see
pug was an interesting case in wasn't
there yes he was well they said that
context wasn't important no the point is
that that was taken off YouTube okay I
mean I can't find examples of it now I
first read about it I thought this guy's
a total [ __ ] you know no I'm not joking
the story that he he is being prosecuted
when you actually see it okay he
explains the context in which it's done
which is his girlfriend basically thinks
his testing it's it's patently clear
that I mean you can always get things
out of context okay which is you know I
mean you know
Twitter's dangerous for that reason
which is that I mean the the the
humorist writer I just got his name is
the sage of Baltimore he was called and
someone will remember I'll remember it
in a second but he was said that there
should be as well as italics in writing
there should be another typeset which
slopes the opposite way which is called
ironic what you're saying
yeah Twitter really needs a kind of
ironic typeset because I've occasionally
made gags which I quite understand if
you completely misunderstood them okay
yes you know they you know it would seem
offensive and I'm occasionally making
the joke in front of the basically to an
imagined audience of a few friends who
will get the fact that it's absurd and
tongue-in-cheek the other 50,000 people
have no way of knowing this so that I
mean that's that's the kind of weird one
and a button yeah I think ultimately you
have to you have to treat free speech as
a line in the sand unless there is some
incitement to physical unpleasantness
okay I accept that but there are cases
where speech can be used but the other
problem is of course that the I mean in
economics in Stingley they've never
possibly wrongly but they've never
accepted what you might call psychic
costs any economic models the reason
being that it's too easy to exaggerate
them so you know if I'm to be harmed
okay physically then patently there will
be some evidence of my being harm but
secondly it's unlikely that I fake that
harm by bashing myself in the face
repeatedly and that does happen okay on
the other hand it's in our interests as
if you look at game theory to exaggerate
the extent to which things upset us now
this is a really interesting case okay
so here's news in cases of parallel my
suspicion is okay eventually a third of
the people in the Heathrow flight path
okay actually like the planes okay right
okay
now however if you're seeking to gain
for the group from Heathrow expansion if
you're seeking to get from that group a
general as much cause if you if you want
that gravity as much compensation as
possible for the disturbance caused okay
me going in the same bloody marvelous
you know 787 full flaps down coming in
low gorgeous the other thing by the way
I don't if you noticed this which is
that people in live in West
very quickly just blackout the planes
completely I used to teach near Gatwick
and you just you just don't notice yeah
but your garden party wants someone like
I think it's something like active okay
I was tell you they're going blah blah
blah glass of red we went to Tuscany
last year we thought we try out British
yeah the people who are local BC didn't
notice yeah anyway but no one's gonna
tell the truth under those conditions
about how much they care about the
planes because they're going to
exaggerate the degree to which the
planes upset them and I wonder I thought
there's a really interesting experiment
which is if you made the deal slightly
different so you said West London okay
through the flight path for new Heathrow
right we're gonna give people living in
Acton people affected by the the runways
really fantastic treatment at Heathrow
gonna get a car park and you can park
there for up to you know three weeks for
a planned a day you can eat your own
lounge right you know we're basically
the West London people who suffer this
Airport when they get to use this
Airport will get treated like bloody
rolls right my hunch is that about half
the people would go actually I don't
really mind the planes if you think
about there's no upside to them except
compensation no upside to Heathrow
expansion really okay the upside is
collective the pain is individual huh
then you have a very clear case where
it's hugely in the interests of those
people to exaggerate things which planes
annoy them because that's how they get
the best payout
yeah no I think you know I think that
there's a danger here which is that we
knew one of the problems about people
claiming offence is that you know
there's some people who have no sense of
human by the way are we gay just as okay
you can't serve a restaurant you can't
operate a restaurant which serves only
food to which nobody is allergic okay
and this isn't the same Talib's minority
rule point which is that a small group
of extreme people can exert a very large
amount of market power
because if the vast majority of people
are happy with a and B okay but there's
a small group that are only happy with
be okay you end up only serving up B
because it's the one thing that
everybody was happy with lowest common
denominator it's like a group thing
isn't it I can't raise it a is it over a
B blood the universal donor which you
can give to everybody okay so the
example I was give this which I gave to
the same Talib is actually blokes I
think prefer spirits and beer to wine
I think wines really overrated is a
drink okay totally overrated nonsense
okay but but if you haven't mixed-gender
party there's a very simple fact which
is about 30% of women won't drink beer
okay and they won't drink cider and they
a lot of them won't drink spirits gin
and tonic Pimm's maybe break that they
actually break the gender bar a bit but
you know but when you there's the
potential that a small group of people
through their own intolerance can
essentially destroy the ecosystem for
everyone else so just as you end up
serving wine because basically women
won't drink certain number of women
won't drink beer now there are only
about 15% of the overall group of the
party but it means that you can't have a
party where you just serve beer men
basically will drink anything sangria
and that bloody Greeks that red sealer
basically I'll drink anything okay so as
a result you have a mixed gender party
red white okay and therefore the
majority end up drinking something they
don't really want to drink simply
because a small group of people won't
drink what they really want to drink and
you will drink what the other people so
you know which is if you have imagine
you had a restaurant where in any
ingredient - which one /
in the world was allergic was taken off
the many of the restaurant knobs you can
have you can serve special dishes to be
blood you know intolerant okay right
okay you can serve special dishes what
you can't do and basically a comedy club
is where you serve the same food to
everybody you can't only serve food to
which nobody's allergic for the simple
reason that the number of foodstuffs you
can probably serve becomes limited to
about four and so your urge to offend
nobody ends up essentially creating
something so anodyne that the the other
ninety five percent of people basically
end up cheated we want to fight that
because you can't you can't have I mean
it's very obscene if you look at in some
interesting cases I mean this seems one
that seems arguments is all carbonated
drinks in the US are kosher okay man
this makes perfect sense by the way but
only about naught point five maybe one
percent of the American population
really follow kosher dietary laws but
it's not worth the coca-cola company
producing separate kosher coke for a
tiny share of the market who wouldn't
drink ordinary coke so it's much easier
just to make you know similarly you know
if you have five percent of
schoolchildren in a London school who
will own eat halal
the whole kitchen goes hello now in that
case bullets but tough on Sikhs if you
knew that because Sikhs technique aren't
supposed to eat halal food for some
reason but Sikh seem pretty chill they
may stay yeah whatever what you have is
is an intransigence of a minority can
end up driving the majority behavior and
I think if we're not careful you know
things like the BBC which are hugely
sensitive and oversensitive to you know
to causing offence yeah I watch most
comedy from the 70s 80s 90s but about
half the time I'm thinking they could
never have done this now in some cases
actually I wish they hadn't now an
interesting example of that would be
about 1/3 maybe 1/4 of the content of
Little Britain ok nice interesting there
are some of them some of the pieces of
Little Britain strike me now as being
actually cruel crueler than their funny
ok or these are their a particularly
sort of extreme stereotype in some shape
most of it's very very good still okay
but there's a lot of stuff which I still
enjoy still think is brilliant and would
still defend to the hilt
which I probably I think the makers of
Little Britain said the same thing
themselves and what happens though if
just like we could never see bands which
happen to appear on TV with Jimmy Savile
okay so all those past examples of Top
of the Pops with Jimmy yeah okay
can never be seen now that's gonna
include a few band performances if we
get to the point where in other words
any comedic sketch from the 1970s 80s or
whatever which would be deemed offensive
to a small group of people can no longer
be shown I mean it's it's off hot mum
for example is involved a character in
blackface okay Oh interesting he
actually spoke fluent I do because he's
grown up in India but he was he played
the Indian Ponca voila
I think if my memory is right now that's
clearly an absolute no-no rebroadcasting
that program you can't rebroadcast The
Dukes of Hazzard not mass produced
comedy in a sense okay but because
there's a Confederate flag on the car I
mean this is kind of weird and equally I
mean I think that Kevin Spacey should be
punished by proper legal process and
then be allowed to rehabilitate his film
career okay
I'm not happy with it you know first of
all I'm not happy with the talent being
completely destroyed without some sort
of legal prosecuted and
you should face you know you should face
prosecution you number one points to
prisoner you'll remember if you look at
prison or very large fines or whatever
it may be all community service ok is
that actually okay there the general
view is one that you do to protect the
public you keep you knock people up to
protect the property secondly you do it
as a deterrent thirdly you might do it
as a literally as a punishment you might
argue there's a that kind of you know
kind of eugenic component to it all that
anything anybody would say that dream of
saying that per second but another
reason another reason for the justice
system is it you know it basically says
once you've done the punishment that's
it over you know there is no necessary
reason why you should not be able to
actually reenter society in some way
now if you if you end up with this kind
of innuendo war probably the most
extreme case was that happening with
them for example that was it Lake
Wobegon guy Garrison Keillor you know
we're you know essentially some you know
some weird allegations surfaces which I
mean he barely remembers an Israeli
unclear you know there is something
slightly dangerous here because upon
something else you are giving people
extraordinary power that simply does
throw mud so that it and and in the hope
of some of it sticking and I'm not
comfortable I mean I'm not you know and
I think that this business where you
essentially you see you see Tinley your
dedication to the cause quite rightly
and I don't understand why people want
to do it and I think most of the social
justice movement is entirely well
intentioned I think the questions about
gender inequality are really intelligent
questions that should be asked
accompanied by the question why though
we company by the assumption it's you
know it's the patriarchy yeah maybe it
is partly in the patriarchy maybe it's
loosely a patriarchy but we got to find
out what it is
because if we're will otherwise we'll
end up with
cure that's worse than the disease if
you if you basically you know if your
diagnosis is of a problem is badly wrong
you end up you know with poisoning
people with medicine essentially yeah
and so so but the urge to signal it
basically leads to a kind of insanity
which I don't think is helpful I mean
I'd like to see wider campaigning for
vegetarianism as I was saying earlier in
one of the things we ought to think
about is the technology but just argue
for different patterns of work at some
level we've got to aim for a four-day
week okay we've got to stop anything for
annualized GDP growth which is easy to
aim for cuz it's a gradual measure and
we got to take the big leap and go okay
our aim for Britain in ten years time is
to have some form of four-day week where
many people either only work four days a
week maybe for longer days possible okay
or can work from home with some degree
of flexibility for one day a week and
part of the purpose of that is to make
it easier if you think about it when
women entered the workforce the amount
of leisure in a married household
dropped by about 48 foot but as a
leisure discretionary time they're not
leisure okay
partly enabled by technology partly able
by the washing machine etc but the
amount of discretionary time in a you
know for a married couple fell by about
forty hours I think we should try and
get some of that time back actually by
reducing the work and I was favorable
yeah I think we have to look at how the
changing working patterns or reducing
working hours or simply giving people
the option to do so because what I said
about this you know this taxi driver
problem with credit cards is it's lots
and lots of people I think I wanted to
instill a thing in Ogilvie where
everybody offered a pay rise whenever
they received a pay rise that's awesome
but they would be given the automatic
option of taking Harvard isn't half of
it as money half that is holiday so four
percent pay rise you could take
basically as 2% cash pay rise at an
extra week's holiday okay
didn't turn up at all but but the point
about that would be that at the moment
there's no mechanism available except by
one being incredibly valuable so they
can't do without you which happens with
some software guys really really
talented software guys usually will
negotiate some sort of flexible are
thing but there isn't a mechanism for
for normal people to actually even state
their preference for the ratio of work
to leisure and it's well it's worth
remembering that it'd be very easy to
make that purely a feminist campaign but
there are tons and tons of men who
probably be asking the same question
it's very very interesting because
actually you know you think well how
much of work that we get done in the
workplace is productive my theory as the
Internet has actually made useful work
20% more productive but at the cost of
growing bureaucracy by about a hundred
percent so ass-covering activities
fatuous presenteeism you know pointless
emails copied to people unnecessarily
unwillingness to take decisions oneself
without engaging five other people it's
actually creating more bad behaviors
that it's that it's it's solved actually
we are probably running out of time yeah
so the one question we always like to
ask our guests before we let them go and
by the way this has been absolutely
fascinating I think we've covered about
half a percent over the thing one I mean
the whole familial DNA thing which is
well I'm not sure about them I'm not
familiar with the story so ordinary cold
case in the u.s. of a guy who is it
seems as variously the Visalia Aram
soccer in the I think the early 70s then
became the east area rapist in
Sacramento and then went on to become
essentially the original night stalker
in other parts of California who says
men can't multitask
[Laughter]
actually slightly monitor he seems
slightly focused on one or the other but
this is a case where very very
interestingly first of all it was DNA
which revealed it was the same person
responsible for all three which freaked
people out secondly unbelievably lucky
in or skilled in getting away for it as
long as he did partly because he seems
to have stopped to the 80s or we assume
that but the other interesting thing is
that weird thing of familial DNA which
is you could go and post to an ancestry
site just in the hope of finding out who
your great-great-grandfather was and the
next thing you know is your second
cousin's doing a seven stretch in the
nonces wing at Wakefield the modern
world and the strangeness of its
consequences opposes the and we're not
good we're very bad at predicting we can
predict first-order consequences sort of
quite well sometimes and she now I'm not
even sure we're good at that I think I
think I'm pretty we would have predicted
from the internet now that people would
have moved out of cities I mean
certainly in the early night you know
mid 90s the prediction was people will
move out of cities gradually and they
will go and work in telling colleges and
they will you know you know essentially
there was going to be this huge
dispersal of people it's crazy
completely opposite because because the
more people you're connected to the more
you need to be able to visit a
megalopolis in order to meet them face
by face to face yeah so you're the
world's airlines have weirdly done very
well out of the internet because to some
extent an email is what you might call a
is the first stage sample of an air trip
yes bility to predict what something
will break is really really terrible so
on that on that very note what do you
think we're not talking about now that
we ought to be talking about what do you
see coming in the future that we ought
to be interested in excited about
concerned about and how do we solve some
of these problems that we've been
discussing today I think we need a
greater level of reflection self
reflection in terms of our motivations
and one of the things I would be
interested in is
a discussion of you know why people
really do the things we do because this
discovery that essentially we do things
following certain instincts and then we
post rationalize or confabulate [ __ ]
explanations for them that strikes me as
just such an interesting and important
insight into humanity in that one of the
questions it raises okay is that I'm not
sure if you want people to adopt more
pro-social or green behavior I'm not
sure the right mechanism is actual
conspicuous altruism so if you look if
you look at the progress in hygiene then
life expectancy was hugely improved
because people's bodily cleanliness and
people's level of home sanitation proved
dramatic people look at the ants from
that period the ABS generally don't say
use pears soap and help prevent a
cholera outbreak it's Darwinian things
like I mean always the bridesmaid never
the bride is actually a line from a
Listerine commercial okay they use huge
sort of fear of singleness fear of you
know desertion status and sexual
attractiveness we're used in huge
quantities to get people to clean their
homes in the same way I don't think
you'll get people to adopt say more
environmental behavior by appeals to
polar bears and appeals to altruism
because I think that kind of signaling
doesn't scale yeah I think it's a
peculiar kind of signaling towards
remember you see that there are large
numbers of status games which only the
rich can play so if you turn up to the
Oscars in a Prius right well you're a
Hollywood megastar it's patently obvious
you could have afforded to turn up in
any car you like so your decision to
never the prayers is a choice not a
compromise okay and you can therefore
signal your care for the environment by
choosing to turn up in our you know a
modest car okay
justice likewise if you're the lead
singer in a rock band you don't have to
practice fantastic hygiene or wear very
fashionable
clothes the reason is you signal exactly
like that a person attic signaling you
signal what you can get away with I mean
oh that's so sexy by dint of being a
lead singer or guitarist that I can
actually still be attractive without
making even the most basic effort around
bodily hygiene okay so that kind of
signaling drives a lot of behavior but
it doesn't always scale because you know
if you're the Mayor of London you tend
to work on a bicycle it's a choice and
it's a signal and it's a status marker
okay if you work at Pizza Express and
each other but it basically means you
couldn't afford a car and so
understanding those things in terms of
how we may need to solve the world's
problems by very oblique means
ultimately people will end up buying
electric cars because they're [ __ ]
cool yeah being actually honest this is
where I think we can wrap this thing on
comedy behavioral science evolutionary
psychology the capacity to be
politically honest about our own true
nature okay is probably necessary to the
solution of quite a little things and
one thing that bothers me I'd mentioned
the fashion question okay now that's now
weird it would be right if men had
something which bear monarchy fashion
and beauty products three trillion
dollars plus a year spent in the world
more than the world spends on education
so okay where there's women's clothes
shop now every single place the women's
clothes shop there was a shop selling
drones okay and I said things to my wife
like I've got undresses wedding on
Saturday so I'll need to buy a new drone
yeah
pretty quickly someone will go what's
ridiculous this has got out of hand you
know we're spending three trillion a
year on these drones masturbate really
obsession with being able to fly things
around the gadgetry okay oh you know if
Hornby was you know like you know the
Louis Vuitton for guys right yeah this
would be really weird okay but there's
because we're trapped by them we're
completely blind to the withers I think
the travel industry has gone whack okay
I don't think
there's any correlation now maybe I can
only say this because I'm kind of rich
and because I've been on some exotic
holidays
I didn't think looking that there's much
of a correlation between how far I
travel how much it costs and how good a
time I have for the few mates to margate
right you can have a fantastic weekend
and you can actually have a fairly [ __ ]
time good to match you picture oh
absolutely the best don't do I ever went
on we went to Buckland slaughtered yeah
it was great it was Williams genuinely
the most fun I've ever had understanding
now actually the best wedding I went to
as a village hall simile I became about
say that is simple of the eight people
who invited me to a wedding how much you
spend how good a time it is is not good
so the question is what I mean I had an
audience in the in the Ogilvie theatre
about 150 people and their typical
bloody Millennials bankers how many
people have been to match you pictures
I've never been how much you pitch you
versus how many people have been to
Lincoln Cathedral right and the ratio
was like four five or six to one yeah so
I'm not dissing much you picked you ten
it's a [ __ ] old stone spectacular
location with a spectacular building its
absolute wrongful achievement okay and
you can get there on the train in a day
okay to go about you pitch you okay
I'm saying having been to match you
pitch you when you haven't been Lincoln
Cathedral is [ __ ] weird the only way
to explain it is basically let's be
honest my Hunnish would be that it's
easier to pull if you've done a year off
isn't just like eleven miserable years
of the life of a labor supporter you've
never really tasted bay leaves until
you've had them in Thailand I could say
if I was trying to channel girls was do
you realize that if you only fire 21
times and Space Invaders when the
spaceship comes across you get a higher
bonus we're kind of traveling but
basically to show off it's is kind of
[ __ ] okay so what a theory which is that
the way we should do this this is my
this is my point that I don't think I'm
right but I think we need absurd
solutions is that when people are about
25 okay the government should give them
an American Express Platinum Card
preloaded with 10 grams okay are they
gonna spend it in a week you could
create a financial product like that
where you put you put in a certain
amount of money okay and then once in
your life you're gonna text it goes okay
you're gonna go week on Thursday and you
base your a week in which you have spent
10 grand
okay and that way you get your five star
hotel you get your front of the plane
you get your bit of exotic [ __ ] okay and
you basically done it okay so the point
about it is that it's only it's not
nearly as magical as you think it is
when you haven't done it yeah so I think
you could create fantastic
egalitarianism by effectively the
equivalent of Rumspringa
above the Amish I think of financial rum
Springer's the answer there you go
free holidays for everyone that's a
great Rory Sutherland thank you so much
for coming on you're on Twitter at Rory
Sutherland you must have a book coming
out at some point shortly yep there's
another one coming up I haven't decided
on the title yet but it's basically
about the the danger of trying to make
everything makes sense the plenty of
things that are evolved system don't
make obvious sense because their role is
complicated embedded and you get rid of
those things at your peril so that's the
book coming out in a year now perfect
well if you if you're kind enough to
come back and chat to us when the book
comes out
you're a draw resettlement Francis I'm
failing human give me a follow give me a
shout yes you do I'm actually gonna
change my Twitter username so it's gonna
be something else at the bottom by the
time this episode comes out thank you
very much for watching trigonometry
subscribe to us on YouTube give us a
rating on iTunes follow us everywhere
that you can Instagram Twitter trigger
pod and we'll see you next week thank
you very much goodbye
[Music]